cela rapporteur général qui va nous
rejoindre mes chers collègues nous
recevons donc ce matin Monsieur Pierre
Moscovici en sa qualité de président du
Haut Conseil des finances publiques
organismes indépendant placé auprès de
la Cour des comptes en application des
dispositions de l'article 61 de la loi
organique relative aux lois de finances
le Haut Conseil rend un avis sur les
prévisions macroéconomiques sur
lesquelles reposent le projet de loi de
finances et le projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale de
l'année et sur la cohérence de l'article
liminaire
au regard au regard des orientations
pluriannuelles de solde de structurel et
de dépenses des administrations
publiques
il se prononce également
sur le réalisme des prévisions de
recettes et de dépenses du projet de loi
de finance de l'année
lorsque le gouvernement révise les
prévisions macroéconomiques sur
lesquelles reposer initialement son
projet le Haut Conseil rend également un
avis sur ses prévisions et l'estimation
de pipe potentiel sur lesquels repose
cette programmation c'est ce qu'il a
fait à l'occasion de la révision du
projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques pour la période 2023
2027 proposé par le gouvernement en vue
de la nouvelle lecture après l'échec de
la CMP de décembre dernier
alors que la croissance devrait être
modeste très modéré en 2024 dans le
contexte de nouveau durcissement de la
politique monétaire et d'une stagnation
de la croissance mondiale
votre éclairage sur la sincérité et la
crédibilité de la trajectoire budgétaire
présentée à la fois pour l'année qui
vient mais également pour la période
quinquennale qui s'ouvre sera évidemment
pour nous tous précieux
je note en particulier le fait que le
scénario macroéconomique sur lequel
repose la programmation pluriannuelle et
pour certaines hypothèses le PLF 2024
vous paraît optimiste dès lors il est
permis de penser que la trajectoire
pourrait pour le moins être difficile à
respecter et sans plus attendre je vous
salue la parole monsieur le président
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur général mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs merci de m'avoir invité de
votre commission au lendemain du
renouvellement de la Haute Assemblée je
félicite les sénateurs élus et réélu en
tant que président du Haut Conseil des
finances publiques pour vous présenter
en effet les présentations principales
conclusions des deux avis que le Haut
Conseil des finances publiques vient de
rendre le premier sur le projet de loi
de finances pour 2024 est une
financement la sécurité sociale et le
second sur le projet de loi de
programmation des finances publiques
pour les années 2024 2027 concernant la
programmation je rappelle que le Conseil
avait déjà rendu un avis l'année
dernière mais le gouvernement en effet
comme vous l'avez dit il a de nouveau
saisi conformément à la lol puisque il a
modifié ces hypothèses macroéconomiques
compte tenu du changement de contexte
depuis un an et mis à jour la
trajectoire finance publique associée
pour prendre en compte également les
autres changements intervenus depuis un
an
dans un premier temps par logique je
présenterai la vie sur le PLF et le
PLFSS pour 2004 et dans un deuxième
temps celui qui porte sur la
programmation plus réelle d'abord le PLF
et le PLFSS pour 2024 concernant ces
deux textes le hcfp examiné conformément
à son mandat les prévisions
macroéconomiques ainsi que le réalisme
des prévisions de recettes et dépenses
le conseil je veux le souligner une fois
n'est pas coutume à bénéficier à sa
demande en ce sens d'un enrichissement
des informations sur les finances
publiques transmises par
l'administration et il a presque eu des
délais normaux donc l'échange a été de
bonne qualité je m'en félicite parce que
nous pouvons ainsi mieux remplir notre
mandat qu'on va moins la réforme
organique de décembre 2021 que vous avez
voté j'en viens aux deux principaux
messages de notre avis
premier message le scénario
macroéconomiquement pour 2024 repose sur
une hypothèse de croissance de plus avec
4% hypothèse que le Haut Conseil en
effet monsieur le président estime élevé
deuxième message la prévision d'un sol
public de moins de 4,4 points de PIB de
ce fait paraître plutôt optimiste
d'abord nous estimons que le scénario
macroéconomique du Grand repose sur du
passage de croissance élevé je
rappellerai avant tout à titre de
contexte que la croissance mondiale
affaiblie en 2023 resterait globalement
à changer en 2024 pénalisé par une
inflation certes en baisse mais toujours
assez élevée et des politiques
monétaires durablement restrictives au
sein des pays développés
l'environnement économique mondial
devrait donc rester peu porteur pour la
croissance française et nos finances
publiques si la croissance a mieux
résister anticipée en 2023 aux
États-Unis en revanche le rebond de la
croissance chinoise résultant de la fin
de la politique de zéroville s'est
révélée de courte durée et la croissance
chinoise devrait rester handicapée par
les équipes croissants économiques on
pense notamment à l'immobilier
parallèlement les commis de la zone euro
traverse une phase de ralentissement
pour l'Allemagne les différents
instituts de conjoncture prévoient une
contraction du PIB sur l'ensemble de
l'année 2023 le retour de la croissance
devrait toutefois intervenir en 2024
mais elle resterait modeste comprise
entre 1 et 1,3% sur une base dégradée
selon les prévisions disponibles enfin
le niveau d'incertitude reste élevé au
niveau mondial en particulier concernant
l'inflation et l'impact durcissement des
politiques monétaires opérés par les
banques centrales selon le cri du
gouvernement la croissance du PIB
s'établirait en France à 1% 2023 et 1,4%
un mot sur la prévision 2023 je dirais
qu'elle est désormais plausible vous
souvenez peut-être qu'elle avait été
jugée un peu élevée par le HCP l'année
dernière à la même époque et qu'elle
était jugée de même en réalité par la
totalité des instituts de prévisions je
voudrais quand même rappeler une chose
ici parce que j'entends après certains
dira vous êtes trompés c'est plus
compliqué que ça la qualité d'une
prévision économique se juge sur son
réalisme au moment où elle est faite en
fonction des informations disponibles
s'il y a ensuite des bonnes surprises
tant mieux mais elle doit être centrale
comme je les économistes et ça n'était
pas le cas à l'époque puisque la
prévision de gouvernement était
supérieure à celle de l'ensemble des
autres prévisions alors disponible
qu'elle supposait donc pour réaliser une
conjonction de facteurs favorables dont
certains se sont réalisés je crois que
cette parenthèse est importante parce
que il peut arriver qu'une prévision
soit dépassée et tant mieux c'est une
bonne nouvelle mais pour autant on doit
baser
la loi de finances sur la prévision du
moment la prison centrale et ça éclaire
les travaux d'aujourd'hui
s'agissant de l'année 2024 justement le
conseil je vous l'ai dit considère que
la prévisions de croissance reçue par le
vent est élevé pourquoi cela parce
qu'elle s'écarte sensiblement de celle
des autres institut prévisions et
légèrement supérieur à celle des
organisations internationales et plus
encore à ce qu'on appelle le consensus
des économistes du mois de septembre qui
s'établit à 0,8% ainsi qu'à celle des
différentes institutions consultées par
le conseil je rappelle que nous
additionnons toujours dans nos avis avec
ses codes l'OFCE et la Banque de France
et tous prévoit une croissance française
comprise entre 0,4 et 09 09 étant la
président de la Banque de France organe
tout de même extrêmement public ça vous
aura pas échappé et qui a tout de même
une forte crédibilité en la matière donc
il y a un écart entre 1,4 et 0,9 au
mieux prévisions élevée certaines
hypothèses du gouvernement Appa raissent
de fait assez fragile il suppose
notamment que le durcissement des
conditions de crédit aura un impact
limité sur l'investissement des
entreprises l'entraidera faible recul de
l'investissement des ménages
ce n'est pas le cas les prévisions des
instituts auditionnés par le conseil il
est vrai que compte tenu des nombreuses
incertitudes qui affectent toute
prévision sur 2024 celle-ci doit être
prise avec prudence mais
si elle n'est pas inatteignable le fait
qu'elle soit éventuellement atteignable
ne signifie pas pour autant qu'elle
continue une bonne base pour construire
une voix donc je dirais élevé mais pas
inatteignable pour résumer mon point de
vue j'en viens maintenant aux prévisions
sur les finances publiques avec une
présence de sol public moins 4,4 points
de PIB qui nous paraît là encore sans
être inatteignable optimiste pourquoi
parce que
nous pensons qu'il y a des hypothèses
favorables tant du côté des recettes que
les dépenses du côté des recettes la
prévisions de prélèvements obligatoires
en 2024 paraît haute puisqu'elle repose
sur une hypothèse de croissance de
l'activité qui sont même optimiste un
cas ou 09 ça va pas générer les mêmes
recettes spontanément au-delà de
l'impact de l'hypothèse de croissance
qui n'est pas négligeable la prévision
de prélèvement obligatoire est aussi
tirée par des hypodex favorables sur le
rendement de certains impôts avec
notamment une croissance prévue de la
TVA supérieure à celle de la base
taxable et un arrêt prévu de la baisse
des droits de mutation à titre onéreux
du côté des
celle-ci augmenterait en 2024 de 3% en
valeur et de 0,5 points en volume la
progression sur cependant nettement plus
sensible une fois qu'on neutralise les
mesures exceptionnelles de soutien face
à la hausse des prix elle atteindrée 4,8
% valeur et 2,2 % en volume ce qui veut
dire qu'en réalité se voit qu'on va
conteste
l'essentiel des économies présentées
telles que 16 milliards problèmes de la
fin ou du retrait de ces dispositifs les
économistes structurelles étant
nettement plus faibles il faut noter
qu'en 2024 le poids des dépenses
publiques dans le pays sera encore super
de 1,5 points ce qu'il était avant la
crise covid ce serait 55,3 contre 53 8
en 2019
j'aimerais souligner ici que sur le
nouveau champ dit du périmètre des
dépenses de l'État la très forte
réduction du coût des mesures de soutien
face à la hausse des prix d'énergie
serait presque compensé par la hausse
résultant des priorités gouvernementales
vous constaterez que la plupart des
ministères ou alors crédits confortés
politique en faveur la transition
écologique 7 milliards en 2024 mesures
d'attractivité pour l'éducation
nationale 3 milliards politiques
sectorielle qui font l'objet de crédit
supplémentaire inscrit dans une loi de
programmation défend justice recherche
intérieure
et la charge d'intérêt enfin
augmenterait en 2024 par 2023 de près de
10 milliards en comptabilité nationale
cette prévision de hausse des dépenses
publiques et par ailleurs sujettes à
plusieurs facteurs possibles de
dépassement c'est vrai notamment du
bouclier de tarifaire sur le prix de
l'électricité dont le coût du Paris
faible vu des prix observez au cours des
derniers mois c'est également le cas des
dépenses de santé sous-ondes pour
lesquelles le gouverne prévoit naître
ralentissement ce qui suppose à
réfléchissement la tendance spontanée
des soins de ville qui semble optimistes
et un volant d'économie de 3,5 milliards
d'euros qui est costaud et difficile à
atteindre dans le contexte actuel de
tension dans le secteur hospitalier de
l'offre de médicaments au total
il ressort de cette analyse
par le Conseil des recettes et des
dépenses que la prévision de déficit
public pour
2024,4 points je le rappelle paraît
optimiste le déficit public de me rate
de toute façon sensiblement supérieure à
la limite de trois points de PIB prévu
par une pâte de sabité en outre alors
que le Conseil de l'Union européenne
demandait à la franc de plafonner à 2,3%
l'augmentation nominale des dépenses
primaires nettes financées au niveau
national en 2024 le grand prévoit sur ce
même périmètre une augmentation de 2,6%
dans le contexte où la progression
importante de la charge d'intérêt
contribue à accroître les dépenses le
PLF contient peu de mesures
d'économistes structurelles malgré le
premier millésime des revues de dépenses
organisées en 2023
ils prévoient également je l'ai dit une
quasi stabilité du taux de PO enfin le
ratio de dette publique ne baisserait
plus en 2024 après une baisse de 2
points 2023 la croissance en valeur du
PIB moins forte en 2024 en 20023 du fait
dure une inflation deviendra en effet
moins favorable c'est pourquoi c'est la
conclusion de notre premier avis le
Conseil continue à appeler à la plus
grande vigilance quant à la
soutenabilité à moyen terme des finances
publiques et donc assez logiquement j'en
viens à la ville au conseil sur la
programmation pluriannuelle révisée dont
il a été saisi par le gouvernement je
l'ai dit et répéter maintes fois devant
votre commission je considère qu'il est
indispensable que la France dotent une
loi de programmation de finances
publiques pour trois raisons
qui demeure valide quoi qu'il arrive
premièrement c'est une partie intégrante
de notre ordre public financier qui
figure à la première ligne de notre
Constitution financière deuxièmement et
au-delà de l'obligation juridique c'est
une nécessité politique et de bonnes
gestion puisqu'elle fixe une trajectoire
de solde et de dette qui donne un cap au
gestionnaire du responsable public et
qui rend aussi plus prévisible et plus
visible l'action publique pour les
citoyens troisièmement l'adoption d'une
LPFP répond aux engagements
communautaires de la France résultant de
la participation à l’excugnant
économique nous devons nos partenaire et
nous nous devons de respecter les
engagements juridiques qui supposent
notamment de nous doter d'une
chorégration Plumelle enfin et ce n'est
pas un argument mineur l'adoption de la
LPF vous le rappeler mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs est un
engagement pris par la France dans le
cadre du plan national de relance et de
résilience et condition ne donc
le paiement de financement européen
important pour notre pays je me félicite
donc que les discussions reprennent sur
ce sujet mais ce projet
et je souhaite ardemment qu'une loi de
programmation de finance publique soit
votée sinon nous entrons dans une série
de turbulences juridique national
européenne et peut-être de problème
financiers à cette échelle néanmoins sur
le fond les observations du Haut Conseil
ne sont pas exemple de critiques et j'en
viens à celle-ci que je présenterai dans
en trois temps d'abord nos observations
sur l'estimation de la croissance
potentielle ensuite aux observations sur
les prévisions macroécémies et enfin nos
observations sur la trajectoire
scientifique d'abord l'activité
potentielle le Fcfp a examiné d'une part
l'estimation d'écart de production du
gouvernement c'est-à-dire son estimation
de la position de l'économie française
dans le cycle économique et d'autre part
c'est la croissance potentielle qui est
presque l'inverse c'est la croissance
tendancelle que connaîtrait l’économie
en l'absence de choc conjoncturelle donc
presque indépendamment du cycle
nous considérons que les deux hypothèses
retenues dans le projet de LPF sont
optimistes le gouvernement légèrement
révisé à la baisse son estimation du PIP
potentiel sur le passé mais son
évaluation de l'écart de production
traduit toujours du point de vue du hcfp
une appréciation optimiste sur la
capacité de rebond les semis françaises
elle suppose que les communes françaises
se situent dans un creux conjoncturel et
dispose donc de capacités de production
utilisée importante mais nous constatons
tous des tensions persistantes sur les
recrutement qui demeure à un niveau
historiquement élevé même s'ils ont un
peu diminué sa licence de la croissance
potentielle le gouvernement a conservé
sa prévision à 35 par sur la période
202327 nous estimons comme l'an passé
que cette prévision est optimiste
c'est vrai que d'autres présidents sont
rapprochent comme celle de l'OFCE pour
le début de la période où salué FMI au
contraire pour la fin de la période mais
c'est quand même la plus élevée de
toutes les prévisions disponibles
supérieure à celle de l'OCDE de la
Banque de France ou encore la Commission
européenne elle suppose que le progrès
technique et l'efficacité des facteurs
de production se remettent à croître
conformément aux tendances en terre la
crise sanitaire ainsi qu'un dynamisme
important de l'investissement des
entreprises malgré le durcissement des
conditions de crédit enfin elle repose
sur une évaluation des effets
indéniables des réformes du marché du
travail que le Fcfp estime trop
importante et trop rapide
j'en passe maintenant au Sénat de
croissance effective pour les années
2023 2027 j'ai déjà indiqué que la
croissance retenue pour 2024 était jugé
élevé pour les années qui suivent de
2025 à 2027 innova de même je dirais
différemment que les prothèses de
croissance du vraiment c'était une
croissance de 7 en 2025 à 2026 puis un 8
en 2007 sont plutôt optimistes parce
qu'elles s'appuie toujours sur une
hypothèse de recul important du taux
d'épargne des ménages qu'on peut
souhaiter mais qui n'est pas dans les
astres aujourd'hui ça suppose également
un niveau élevé des bâtiments aux
entreprises
et nous avons toujours le durcissement
les conditions de crédit enfin une
contribution légèrement positive du
commerce électeur à la croissance que
nous espérons tous mais ce qui au vu des
tendances passées apparaît quand même
comme favorable et donc
je dirais comment septembre dernier
peut-être à moindre titre le cinéma
le salon bacroéconomique du gouvernement
ne repose pas sur une prévision
totalement irréaliste donc vous m'avez
parlé de sincérité je déteste le débat
sur la sincérité la sincérité suppose
l'intention de tromper il s'agit pas de
ça et je pense par ailleurs que
l'existence du conseil au débats ont
permis de ramener les prévisions dans un
un écart ils sont raisonnable sur lequel
on peut discuter donc nous ne sommes pas
dans l'insatérité nous ne sommes pas
dans l'irréalisme absolu mais nous
sommes quand même dans non dans des
nous ne sommes pas dans l'irréalisme si
vous préférez je me reprends car très
attention ce n'est pas inatteignable
encore une fois mais sa combine quand
même des hypothèses favorables ce qui
est une nature a fragiliser la
réalisation des objectifs de finances
publiques qui sont présentés et
justement
le Haut Conseil examiné concrètement à
son mandat la cohérence de cette
trajectoire avec les engagement
européens de la France
alors
l'objectif de moyen terme de la France
et d'atteindre un défi de structurel
d'eau plus 0,4 points de PIB or en fin
de programmation le défi de structurel
s'établirait à 2,7 points de PIB soit un
niveau beaucoup plus élevé et très
éloigné de cet objectif de moyen terme
je reconnais quand même que au stade où
nous en sommes atteindre le MTO comme on
dit est assez
dur et même pas souhaitable mais quand
même la réduction du déficit paraît
lente et j'ajoute que le gouvernement
envisage un retour sous trois points de
PIB uniquement en 2027 c'est un peu
amélioré par rapport au projet initial
puisque c'était deux neuf l'an dernier
c'est de 7 cette année mais nous serions
quand même si on regarde les problèmes
de stabilité au partenaire certes
déposer il y a 5 mois
aucun ne prévoit un retour sous trois
points aussi tardif l'Irlande
la Grèce la Grèce l'Allemagne le
Portugal les Pays-Bas ont déjà un
déficit inférieur à 3 points en 2022
l'Espagne sera en 2024 l'Italie en 2025
la Belgique en 2026
enfin dans ce projet révisé le
gouvernement vise une baisse un peu plus
forte du ratio de République et le
progénitien
jemplélite parce que c'est ce qu'a
souhaité le HFP quand même la réduction
de l'endettement serait modeste
puisqu'on serait à 108 points de PIB en
ça veut dire quelques trois points ou 4
ans 25 ans
à ce rythme là les 60% ne sont pas pour
demain pour un horizon raisonnable pour
chacun d'entre nous autour de la table
presque seront tous keynésiens
nous lui souhaitons
et donc c'est quand même une trajectoire
donc on peut définir comme peu
ambitieuse regarde des engagements
européens même s'il est un peu meilleur
que le projet initial et c'est d'autant
plus regrettable que la crédibilité de
la trajectoire peut être discuter
puisqu'elle suppose des dépenses hors
charges d'intérêt quasi stables sur la
période 2024 2027 et qu'une croissance
des 0,1 points volume ce qui est bien
plus ambitieux que ce qui était réalisé
par le passé à titre de comparaison la
carte pendant la croissance de la
dépense était la plus contenue au cours
des 20 dernières années est une période
que je connais un peu
2010-2014 c'est à dire pendant la crise
des dettes souveraines en zone euro
mais alors les dépenses hors chardonner
de 0,9 points en volume donc il
s'agirait de faire beaucoup plus que de
plus ambitieux qui était fait au cours
des dernières années
et cette progression très limitée des
dépenses proposent notamment sur un
effort marqué des réductions des
dépenses de l'État moyen terme qui
baisseraient de 0,9 points volume
Toto quand même ce qui est un facteur
aggravant nous disons compliquant que
certaines dépenses seront plus
dynamiques en raison des lois de
programmation sectorielles par exemple
pour la défense qui ont été examinés par
le Conseil et beauté par vous et les
autres dépensent de l'État celles qui ne
sont pas couvertes par des bloc
progression devront dès lors très
fortement mais c'est la maîtrise de la
dépense je le signale devant la route
d'assemblée reposerait également sur la
baisse des dépenses de fonctionnement
des collectivités locales qui s'est bien
à 0,5 points par an en moyenne sur la
période 2024 2027 cela sans mécanismes
contraignant pour y parvenir ainsi que
sur l'hypothèse d'une baisse de leurs
investissements je vous laisse apprécier
ça veut dire dans le cycle électoral que
vous connaissez désormais mieux que moi
qui l'ai complètement oublié ces
évolutions prévues
ique rapidement ces évolutions prévues
pourraient toutefois être en partie
contrariée par certains investissements
notamment ceux qui sont nécessaires à la
transition écologique dont on demande
par ailleurs qu'il s'appuie beaucoup sur
les collectivités locales
enfin les dépenses d'administrations de
sécurité sociale augmenteraient en
moyenne en volume de 0,8 points sur les
places 2024 2027 c'est un rythme
inférieur du PIB
ceci repose sur la montée en charge
progressive de la vente de retraite au
milieu au printemps mais aussi sur une
progression des dépenses sousondables
limitées à 2,9 en fin de période ce qui
suppose un effort de maîtrise très
conséquent au total le respect de la
trajectoire suppose la réalisation d'un
montant important d'économie le
gouvernement escompte 12 milliards
d'euros des colis pérennes en 2025
répartit entre l'État la sphère sociale
issu de l'exercice de revue des dépenses
dont le contenu concret reste à préciser
qui à mon sens reste a renforcé
considérablement j'en parlerai si vous
souhaitez mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs et j'ajoute enfin
que ce montant important l'économie est
toujours très peu documenté à ce stade
nous avons des données sur les retraites
et sur l'assurance chômage nous n'avons
pas sur le reste en conséquence la
baisse attendue du ratio d'une dette
publique est fragile puisqu'elle
s'appuie sur une prévision de croissance
optimiste une cible exigeante de
dépenses dont le respect d'aujourd'hui
pas garanti par une documentation très
concrète
je veux tirer quelques conclusions pour
terminer Monsieur le Président sur la
porte en général mesdames le point
le plus saillant qu'il faut retenir je
le gardais pour la fin c'est quand même
l'augmentation spectaculaire elle est là
de la Charte de la dette dès 2024 et
surtout que la perte de programmation
revenons un tout petit peu en arrière en
2021 c'est pas il y a très longtemps la
charge de la dette était de 31 milliards
d'euros l'an prochain elle sera de 57
milliards d'euros soit plus que le
budget de la défense
en 2027 elle sera ce sont les chiffres
du gouvernement de 84 milliards d'euros
presque triplés en six ans et à ce
moment là ce serait pour la première
fois devant le budget de l'Éducation
nationale
ça fait longtemps que j’allerte devant
vous au nom du au Conseil de la Cour des
comptes devant les risques de
l'endettement nous ne sommes plus devant
les risques mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs ils sont là la hausse des taux
est là
prenez l'austérité ça n'a jamais été ma
tasse de thé j'ai une longue expérience
publique je crois à l'action publique je
crois la volonté politique je suis
convaincu que le volant d'économie qui
est présenté n'est pas impossible à
réaliser beaucoup d'autres pays l'ont
fait mais pour ça il faut changer nos
comportements collectifs il faut changer
de méthode faire passer à des vrais
revues de dépenses qui soulèvent
vraiment le capot des politiques
publiques et qui font le tri entre ce
qui marche qui doit être conforté et ce
qui ne marche pas sur lequel il faut
réaliser des économies beaucoup plus
fortes et structurelles
je ne crois pas au rabots je ne crois
pas une forme de pensée magique qui fera
en sorte que la croissance seule
produise une augmentation indéfinie des
recettes ça ne résoudra pas notre
équation de finance publique il faut une
action déterminée et collective j'ajoute
enfin que personne ne souhaite que notre
pays se trouve dans une situation où des
tensions sur la dette conduira des
coupes brutales dans la dépense d'une
part ou à des augmentations fortes
d'impôts avec dans les deux cas des
conséquences très dommageables pour les
ménages et les entreprises parce que
pour le coup ça s'appelle l'austérité
je ne veux pas dire que ce risque nous
guette aujourd'hui je ne pense pas que
la France soit en faillite ni en risque
je pense que sa dette est soutenable
c'est à dire finançable mais la sagesse
et je suis ici dans la chambre de la
sagesse recommande de ne pas attendre
que le risque apparaisse pour agir il
sera alors trop tard voilà Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs les quelques
réflexions que je voulais faire
sur ces deux avis du Haut Conseil et je
suis maintenant à votre disposition pour
répondre à vos questions
aidé par l'équipe qui m'entoure qui a
fait comme toujours avec les membres du
Haut Conseil un formidable travail dans
des délais tout de même extrêmement
acrobatique je crois que nous pouvons
être fiers de l'existence de conseils et
de son utilité je le suis en tout cas
merci monsieur le Président poursuit
finalement deux présentations dont une
seule sur le projet de loi de finance
dont nous avons une certaine façon la
primeur ce matin
tout à fait je ne fais rien à la
dilégale c'est prévu comme ça le conseil
ce n'est pas ce que j'indiquer le
conseil je voulais m'en féliciter le
Conseil rend son avis le matin avant que
se présentait le PDF en conseil Michou
pendant qu'il est il vient le présenter
aux chambres qui lui reçoit et c'est
devant vous en effet que je le fais en
premier j'irai ensuite à l'Assemblée
nationale où j'étais lundi mais c'était
un peu compliqué pour vous présenter le
deuxième avis sur le PLF après avoir
présenté le premier je suis un homme ne
vous excusez pas de passer devant le
Sénat avant l'Assemblée nationale il y a
pas de problème je me réjouis j'explique
simplement que nous sommes tout à fait
dans les clous évidemment nous sommes
pas de griller je ne sais quel c'est le
président parlons voilà ni pension même
pas merci monsieur le rapporteur général
merci monsieur le Premier Président à
vous à vous-même évidemment et à vos
équipes vous avez
je pense dressé
un constat alors exigeant prudent
nous alertants collectivement
effectivement et nous sommes sensibles
au fait que vous avez choisi
votre intervention au Sénat moi j'y vois
un signe c'est l'assemblée la plus
fraîchement impacté par un
renouvellement démocratique ce qui me
permet également de féliciter l'ensemble
des collègues présents réélu
mais vous avez aussi terminé
par une image en disant qu'il
y avait besoin de soulever le capot pour
modifier finalement les réglages du
moteur moi je vais garder cette image et
évidemment je me ferais fort de rappeler
au chef de garage le ministre de
l'économie et des finances de procéder
désormais et de manière fine mais active
et volontariste assez réglages qui me
paraissent indispensable le dernier
slide qui est devant nous sur l'envolée
de la dette alors il y a deux ans lors
d'un présentation en commission du
budget nous avions alerté sur les
dangers d'une dette
qui pourrait s'apparenter à terme qui
aurait pu s'apparenter à terme à court
terme même un mur de dette le chef de
garage nous avait répondu effectivement
que c'était un mauvais PIMS pessimisme
que tout ça allait plutôt dans le bon
sens et je le redis parce que vous
l'avez dit il faut toujours resituer
dans le juste contexte au moment où on
prononce les uns les autres nos habits
nous l'avions dit en disant qu'il y
avait quand même un risque de voir un
moment les taux remontés
je pensais pas qu'il remonterait aussi
vite quelques quelques éléments vous
avez sur les prévisions de croissance
alors j'ai entendu là encore vos
précautions oratoires mais je tous les
mots vous avez utilisé me paraissent
marqué du Saut du doute un doute
parfois certains et parfois très fort
c'est ni insécurite à sincérité ni
irréalisme ni inatteignable il y en a
qu'un que vous n'avez pas mis mais c'est
normal la lettre N est remplacée par
l'extrême pas dit que c'était impossible
mais pour moi dans tous les cas les
scénarios sont marqués je le redis d'un
profond doute je souhaitais d'ailleurs
parce que il y a un élément que qui me
paraît important c'est que dans la
stratégie budgétaire et fiscale
cette stratégie repose sur une baisse
des dépenses mais qui n'est
malheureusement absolument pas documenté
je dirais donc elle est lacunaire et je
pense que c'est une préoccupation parce
que pour tout vous dire
un certain nombre de mes collègues
lorsque nous avons tout au long de l'été
fait campagne les élus locaux
s'interrogent fortement sur le sujet de
la soutenabilité à la fois des
prévisions et de la capacité pour les
collectivités à contribuer au
redressement des finances publiques
alors vous avez dit pas les beaucoup
plus loin il n'y a pas un sincérité mais
finalement si j'ose qu'est-ce qui manque
aujourd'hui ou que faudrait-il de plus
pour pouvoir dire que le la présentation
qui est faite sur le scénario
macroéconomique et l'évolution des
finances publiques serait insert et puis
un deuxième élément
en fait depuis l'introduction en droit
français de la LPFP 2008 on s'aperçoit
que il n'y a eu depuis ces 15 ans plus
tard aucune aucune amélioration des de
la situation des finances publiques
elles se sont dégradées
avez-vous à ce stade des orientations
des
indications ou des règles nouvelles à
évoqué ou à proposer qui pourrait
permettre de mieux répondre et surtout
de corriger cette fâcheuse tendance qui
vous l'avez dit dans les comparaisons
européennes qui frappent la France bien
davantage et vous avez parlé de changer
nos comportements collectifs je pense
que nous y adhérons tous alors c'est
douloureux mais un moment à force de
vouloir reculer soit le temps du
diagnostic soit surtout les soins
apportés pour réduire la douleur
ça peut s'avérer je dirais très
dangereux pour l'avenir du pays quelques
éléments sur les nouvelles règles
européennes puisqu'elles sont également
en fond de carte
au niveau européen sur
la gouvernance économique et budgétaire
les règles actuelles vous l'avez déjà
dit ne sont pas pleinement
satisfaisantes avez-vous des
préconisations et surtout peut-être que
pensez-vous aujourd'hui des propositions
de la Commission
s'il y avait des règles budgétaires
modifiées d'ailleurs la LPFP ne
deviendrait-elle pas presque aussitôt
caduque et dans ce cas là
qu'elle serait l'attitude de la France
une
vous avez évoqué enfin la difficulté à
concilier les règles budgétaires avec le
nombre important de loi de programmation
sectorielle qui ont été votées et
adoptés nous amenons d'ailleurs dans une
situation là encore comme l'on dit les
élus que j'ai rencontrés dans tous les
domaines une situation malheureusement
très compliquée
puisque nous appelons des économies et
dans le même temps nous proposons des
envolés des budgets pour rattraper des
situations
anciennes difficiles mais voilà il y a
peut-être aussi ça nous touche également
certaines incohérences enfin parce que
je ne veux pas manquer le sujet des
finances sociales
avez-vous un avis puisque finalement moi
je m'interroge sur la diminution
programmée de la part de la T2A dans la
dame pour les établissements de santé
comment selon vous parvenir à réguler
efficacement les dépenses des hôpitaux
faut-il passer par une régulation des
dotations
c'est une c'est une une vraie question
et puis
quel mécanisme selon vous
pourrait-on mettre pour réguler les
soins de ville puisque il y a un lien
entre les prescriptions des soins de
ville et ensuite la le passage entre
guillemets
aux dépenses hospitalières
voilà monsieur le Premier Président un
certain nombre de mes interrogations
mais je pense que mes collègues vont
être peut-être encore plus gourmands ou
plus curieux que moi
merci Monsieur rapporteur général il me
semble que vous avez déjà formulé un
nombre de questions extrêmement
significatif et donc je vais proposer au
président s'il le veut bien de vous
répondre dans un premier temps de
prendre les questions de nos collègues
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
rapporteur général aux questions tout
extrêmement aiguë
s'adresse en fait pour beaucoup au
président de la Cour des comptes
davantage qu'aucun de vos conseils et
finances publiques je lui dis parce que
au Conseil a un mandat bien précis qu'il
remplit précisément et il revient pas
d'aller plus loin sur un certain nombre
de ces sujets comme je connais un peu le
premier président de la Cour des comptes
je vais essayer de jongler avec
tout en tout en précisant que les sujets
sur lesquels je peux pas aller trop loin
d'abord sur le lance sincérité ou la
sincérité pour le coup c'est pas du tout
au conseil que ça revient de l'apprécier
c'est en matière budgétaire au Conseil
constitutionnel de le faire qui en a
déjà donné une définition assez précise
selon le Conseil elle se caractérise par
l'absence d'intention de fausser les
grandes lignes de liquide déterminent
pas loin de finances qui veut dire que
en réalité il faudrait l'intention
déterminer de les fossés pour être
insensé
mon prédécesseur
plus que l'argent sur la fonction la
même exercé avait jugé en 2017 que la
loi de finance pour cette année avait
été insère
à l'époque j'étais commissaire j'avais
pas été d'accord avec lui je l'avoue
justement parce que je ne voyais pas
d'intention de tromper donc vraiment je
crois que c'est un mot qu'il faut se
garder d'utiliser et je ne ressens
absolument pas que ce soit le cas cette
fois je le dis les prisons de croissance
sont élevés
et elles sont plus élevées que la
totalité des instituts prévisions pour
autant elles sont pas inatteignables et
il y a une série de raisonnements
sous-jacents et de Paris sur l'avenir
que le ministre des Finances et le
ministre grand public viendront vous
exposer ici
je pense que c'est difficile et au stade
où nous en sommes en tout cas personne
ne peut dire que cette prévision soit
centrale donc elle est optimiste voilà
ce que je peux dire mais je n'utilise en
rien le mot d'insaltérité vraiment et je
vous assure que c'est indépendant de
toute conciliation politique je
m'engarde toujours c'est un mot un peu
explosif et qui suppose une intention
qui n'est pas alors si par exemple on
avait une prévision de croissance à 2%.
il est arrivé avant l'existence de votre
conseil qu'on est des prévisions
complètement en dehors des clous
à ce moment là nous pourrions
courir soulever ce risque là je le dis
c'est élevé mais pas inatteignable sous
un certain nombre de conditions
extrêmement favorable qui se trouverait
réuni par un concours de circonstance
pourquoi pas
et d'ailleurs le gouvernement vous
objectera que les dernières tout le
monde s'est trompé que ok moi je suis là
dessus un tout petit peu plus prudent
parce que ce que je constate c'est qu'il
y a eu un premier trimestre qui était
conforme aux prévisions un troisième et
quatrième trimestre qui ont repris une
pente assez neutre et un deuxième
trimestre extrêmement bon pour des
raisons en partie inexpliquées donc il
ne fait pas une tendance voilà
là on est quand même à 0,5 points
d'écart entre la présidente et la Banque
de France c'est beaucoup
beaucoup
où faire des économies là encore une
fois c'est pas à nous de le faire
je dirais que
je vais surtout faire une précision de
méthode c'est de procéder à des revues
de dépenses beaucoup plus approfondie
que celle qu'on a commencé à faire je me
réjouis les premières revues de dépenses
je constate qu'elles ne sont pas
publiques je pense qu'elles sont ont été
quasi exclusivement techniques et
internal administration si vous regardez
le rapport de la Cour des comptes sur la
situation les perspects des finances
publiques paru en juin il y a tout un
chapitre que j'ai été venu vous
présenter avec les préconisations sur
comment faire il faut que les revues
dépenses concernent à la fois
l'investissement et le fonctionnement
quelle touche toute la dépense
c'est-à-dire à la fois l'état les
colloques et la sécurité sociale que ce
soit fait avec les acteurs donc une
procédure un peu démocratique en la
matière et enfin que ce soit fait dans
la durée
et pas uniquement de manière saisonnière
de la confection de la loi de finances
tant qu'on en fait pas ça on pourra pas
en effet ouvrir le capot monsieur
général
je dis que la Cour des Comptes est
disponible pour y participer nous avons
présenté 9 notes thématiques vous êtes
peut-être consulté sur des sujets comme
logement l'éducation les dépenses
fiscale les aides aux entreprises qui ne
prétendent pas l'exhaustivité mais qui
je pense sont intérêts donc voilà ce que
je peux dire sur les règles européennes
je ferai deux points le premier pour
dire que nous sommes dans une situation
où
logiquement les règles européennes
seront rétablies le 1er janvier 2024
dans quelques mois la question c'est
quelle règle et quelles conséquences
si ce sont les règles actuelles qui
reviennent avec tous leurs effets
pervers
[Musique]
car très contraignant théoriquement
alors on pourrait avoir une vague de
mise en procédure pour tester excessif
dont la France et que cette situation
c'est pas naturellement une cible tout à
fait privilégiée
nous avons intérêt
je dirais tous à ce que ce soit les
règles réformées qui rentrent en vigueur
de ce point de vue là je donne un point
de vue de tout personnel qui a été
repris par la Cour des comptes et il y a
un encadré dans la vidéo hcfp qui est
que la base de la commission est plutôt
saine c'est à dire substituer tout en
gardant les critères
à une approche très globale et
tournée vers la sanction une approche
tournée vers l'incitation avec des
profils de dettes nationaux
et un gain de temps qui dépendrait du
quantum de réforme qu'on est capable de
faire ce serait quand même exigeant pour
les pays les plus endettés mais c'est
plus intelligent je sais qu'il y a des
débats elle regroupe je continue de les
suivre
ça m'intéresse quand même
et que je vois que l'Allemagne a durci
sa position je souhaite ardemment que
peut-être avec un travail commun avec
nos amis espagnols et néerlandais un
compromis soit trouvé dans les mois qui
viennent ça me paraît tout à fait
nécessaire mais encore une fois si vous
sentiment voilà la base de la commission
me paraît plutôt la meilleure
pour ce qui est quel était votre
question la quatrième c'était sûr je
pense sociale les dépenses sociales bon
là je vais pas
me lancer dans de longs développements
sur les dépenses sociales pour le coup
je revois toute une série de rapports de
la Cour des comptes et je reviendrai
bien volontiers devant vous pour
présenter cela tant que premier
président mais je veux faire une
remarque comme prison de conseils
c'est que les chiffres qui sont donnés
sur mon âme
suppose quand même à la fois les
conditions favorables et les économies
très fortes
et que c'est pas simple et qu'il faudra
pour le coup trouver des remèdes assez
vigoureux pour parvenir aux hypothèses
qui sont là ce qui nous permet de dire
qu'elles sont elles aussi favorables et
dès lors qu'elles sont favorables ça
veut dire que les dépenses telles
anticipées risquent de dépassement ce
qui n'est pas sans conséquence sur
l'équilibre des finances publiques
merci monsieur le Président nous allons
donc reprendre nos vieilles habitudes
c'est-à-dire essayer de tenir nos
questions en deux minutes s'il vous
plaît et pour donner le rythme Vincent
Delahaye en premier merci monsieur le
Président merci monsieur le président du
Haut Conseil des finances publiques
vous nous avez fait un bel exposé qui en
réalité confirme ce que l'on pense ici
depuis un petit moment de façon assez
majoritaire je pense que l'optimisme
règne dans la gestion de nos finances
publiques et autant j'aime bien
l'optimisme dans la vie mais autant en
matière de gestion de l'argent public se
trouve que c'est un grave défaut et pour
moi c'est la rigueur et la prudence qui
devrait plutôt
prévaloir donc
ma question quand j'avais deux questions
d'abord pensez-vous que vos avis et
votre avis là en l'occurrence quoi sur
les deux textes puissent modifier les
hypothèses du gouvernement
et ma deuxième question c'est est-ce que
vous pensez que
les la fin des dépenses exceptionnelles
devraient aurait dû permettre en tout
cas de d'assister à une baisse de la
dépense publique
merci Vincent
vermillier
votre voisine merci monsieur le
Président merci
du président pour ces deux avis j'ai
deux questions par rapport à l'évolution
pluriannuelle cette trajectoire proposée
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de l'impact
de l'annonce de Bruno Le Maire à propos
de la
suppression ou non suppression de la
CVAE c'est-à-dire
que qui devait être supprimés en deux
ans et qu'il le serait seulement depuis
2017 2027 et puis vous avez à peine
évoqué la question de la réforme des
retraites mais par rapport au budget de
la Sécurité sociale
que comment concevez-vous l'impact de la
réforme des retraites sur l'activité
économique merci
merci Sylvie Christine Lavarde
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président alors merci pour ce propos
éclairé avec le vocabulaire cherché du
Haut Conseil des finances publiques je
me semble que le rapporteur général de
l'Assemblée nationale partage votre
vision puisque je lisais ce matin qu'il
indiquait déjà qu'il allait falloir
faire un nouveau une révision du budget
au cours de l'exercice de l'année 2024
alors on apprécie vos propos mais je
l'avais déjà déploré précédemment et je
renouvelle cette demande il serait utile
pour nous en fait d'avoir un contrefa
actuel c'est à dire que c'est bien de
nous dire que les hypothèses sont
optimistes mais ce serait intéressant de
voir comment bougerait le déficit le
solde si jamais on prenait des
hypothèses qui vous paraissent celles de
la moyenne en tout cas du consensus en
tout cas ça éclairerait très utilement
notre appréciation sur la copie qui nous
est présentée
de même vous avez une diapositive sur le
taux de prélèvement obligatoire cette
année il me semble qu'arrive à échéance
89 niches fiscales le gouvernement
n'évoque pas du tout ce sujet dans PLF
qui sera publié là enfin dans les
prochaines heures ou minutes est-ce que
vous avez fait un travail d'évaluation
de ce que représente en fait cette
imposition supplémentaire si les 90
fiscales devaient effectivement
s'arrêter au 31 décembre et enfin ma
dernière remarque afin juillet 2023 le
déficit de la France pour l'année 2023 a
atteint 169 milliards c'est 30 milliards
de plus qu'à la même date en 2022 c'est
même un niveau plus élevé que en 2020 et
en 2021 on était en année covid donc
est-ce que vous pensez que la
l'hypothèse 2023 est crédible puisque on
a tout recalculé sur ce qui a été
annoncé mais début de l'exécution
laisse apparaître quelques doutes
merci Christine Bernard delcro
oui merci monsieur le président
une question sur la nécessaire réduction
des dépenses vous nous avez indiqué
Monsieur le Président je n'ai jamais été
partisan de l'austérité et vous nous
avez dit je cite il faut une action
déterminée collective pour diminuer la
dépense pourriez-vous nous préciser un
peu nous donner quelques pistes sur
cette voie de l'action déterminée et
collective en sachant qu'évidemment il
faut tenir compte des hausses qui sont
déjà gagés si je peux dire dans les lois
de programmation sectorielles comme vous
l'avez rappelé
merci merci Bernard
Rémi Ferro
merci monsieur le Président
Messieurs les Présidents d'ailleurs
une remarque quelle que soit nos avis
politiques différents
l'augmentation de la charge de la dette
durable
change les éléments changent la donne et
donc doit changer aussi les éléments de
notre réflexion je crois qu'on en est
tous je crois qu'on en est tous
conscients ensuite une question vous
avez fait monsieur le Président vous
avez une allusion à la trajectoire
financière pour les collectivités
locales avec une diminution prévue des
dépenses en volume sans mécanisme
coercitif en tout cas sans mécanisme
coercitif très clair à ce stade est-ce
que vous avez des précisions sur
la contribution de finances locales à la
trajectoire à la fois sur l'endettement
et le déficit public dans les années qui
viennent est-ce que c'est très faible
faible ou important dans la trajectoire
du gouverte qui nous est présenté par le
gouvernement et que vous vous envisagez
réaliste
je ne vois pas d'autres d'autres
questions alors j'en aurai une moi
monsieur le Président si vous me
permettez je rappellerai que nous avons
le même âge
et vous faites plus jeune
mais ce que je voulais en tirer comme
élément c'est que nous avons sans doute
travailler sur les mêmes livres
et notamment en matière économique un
des livres de l'époque c'était le bar
l'été qui était la Bible une des Bible
mais une des Bible
et quand on parlait
on t'en parler finalement des questions
liées à l'augmentation de charges
d'intérêt de la dette en même temps dans
le bar on pouvait lire que c'était pour
partie compenser par l'augmentation des
recettes de l'État tant que tant que
tant que les taux d'intérêt
finalement réel était finalement
inférieur à l'inflation
c'était ce qu'on apprenait à l'école
alors l'économie a beaucoup changé
depuis mais est-ce que
il y a un peu de vrai là dedans toujours
j'ai pas tout à fait condamné le
professeur bar
et
s'il y a un peu de vrai
comment peut-on l'affecter à ces
chiffres d'augmentation de charges
d'intérieur autrement dit je précise
bien ma question entre 2023 et 2024 nous
aurons toujours
une augmentation
de
l'inflation mais est-ce que elle est
contrebalancée pour partie
et à quel niveau par une augmentation
des recettes de l'État autrement dit les
chiffres bruts sont une chose
les chiffres les comparaisons
mériteraient peut-être de voir ce point
sachant c'est pas pour dire qu'il y a
pas un problème
évidemment mais que en fait le problème
va d'autant plus s'aggraver le jour où
l'inflation repassera en dessous des
taux de
c'est le président
je commencerai par votre question
monsieur le Président mais c'est vrai
que nous avons le même âge que peut-être
à un moment donné
à peu près les mêmes études mais
aujourd'hui
je vais faire une confession j'étais
sans doute beaucoup plus à gauche que
vous à l'époque c'est pas impossible
et donc j'allais pas beaucoup au cours
du professeur bar néanmoins
simplement
pour revenir plus sérieux
je vais très simple d'abord sur
l'inflation
ces chiffres sur lesquels je me suis pas
étendu les sites d'inflation sont
considérées par nous comme plausible
avec peut-être des petits risques de
dépassement quand même la prévision en
l'occurrence nous n'estimons pas élevé
mais en dessous quand même de ce que
disent les prévisions et on pourrait
avoir sur ce point des mauvaises
surprises
si je peux paraître un petit peu
d'intuition je constate comme sur
l'inflation nous avons un discours
depuis quelques temps qui est plutôt
toujours ça va s'arrêter ça
tarde au passage c'est pas scientifiques
monsieur Dubois me regarde avec un
regard mauvais donc je m'arrête
c'est plutôt possible avec un petit
risque de dépassement c'est ce que dit
le au conseil
quant à au sein de l'État elles
expliquent pour beaucoup
les
relativement bonne performances
budgétaire que nous avons connu ces
dernières années
logiquement dans la zone euro et en
France
la dynamique de la recette devrait être
beaucoup moins bonne sans que ce soit
possible chiffré dans la vie qui vient
et dans les années suivantes autrement
dit cette espèce de formidable surprise
qui permet d'avoir un taux de
prélèvement obligatoire qui augmente
avec des baisses d'impôts très
importantes 50 milliards d'euros ça
pourrait ne pas être absolument
définitif d'où le fait que le professeur
bar rétrospectivement
nous pourrions convenir qu'il avait
raison
j'en viens maintenant aux questions
posées
on nous demande à nous de les estimer
de tes jugements
crédibilité notre avis est là
et il est une boussole utile pour vous
j'espère
pour le Conseil constitutionnel pour les
institutions européennes c'est ça notre
rôle chacun est à sa place j'ai trop
fait de politique pour prétendre quoi
que ce soit me substituer à lui chacun
est dans son rôle
après sur les dépenses exceptionnelles
c'est une question que vous avez posée
la hausse de la dépense publique en 2024
était estimée par le gouvernement à 3%
en valeur et 0,5 en volume
or l'impact de l'extinction des dépenses
exceptionnelles li aux différentes
crises sanitaires énergétiques cette
hausse serait en volume de
2,5%. et la relative stabilité des
dépenses publiques en 2024 et donc
surtout permises surtout pas
l'extinction en cours des différentes
mesures considères comme d'urgence et
non pas par des économistes
structurelles et le Conseil remarque par
ailleurs que la baisse des mesures de
soutien face à l'inflation énergétique
entraîne le remplacement que dépense
sexuels par des dépenses pérennes en
août nous notons les incertitudes
entourant la réalisation de ces prisons
de dépenses j'ai cité déjà la dame
ce qui veut dire que
cette année vous présenter 16 milliards
d'économies dont 12 ne sont pas
structurelles en gros 12 et demi
pour les années suivantes la marche est
plus compliquée parce que pour le coup
le quoi qu'il en coûte n'existera plus
et donc les 12 milliards d'euros
pérennes structurelles et à ce jour ils
sont peu documentés hors retraite et
assurance chômage
madame monsieur madame Vermeillet sur la
CVAE
bon cette chose que je puis dire
là-dessus
d'un point de vue que j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de
d'exprimer à plusieurs reprises c'est
que je pense que dans notre situation de
déficit nous n'avons pas nous n'avons
pas les moyens de faire des tests sèches
ça veut pas dire qu'il faut se priver de
tout usage fiscalité elle joue un rôle
de location un rôle de redistribution
tous les manuels économiques pour le
coup le disent depuis longtemps et c'est
l'essence même de la politique c'est ce
qu'ils font d'ailleurs des choix
largement différents ici
mais avec une stabilité me semble-t-il
au moins en termes de prélèvement et
donc des baisses de cbae pourquoi pas
c'est une décision politique mais ce que
je dis pour le coup ce que dit beaucoup
c'est que dans cette hypothèse là il
faut la compenser soit par des
prélèvements de nature différente soit
des économies supplémentaires a dû
concurrence
c'est sans doute qui explique d'ailleurs
le choix de ralentir la baisse de la TVA
mais ça c'est une question
peut-être que vous pourrez poser au
ministre de la suggère pas mais
existe
sur les questions de Madame l'avare
comme d'habitude extrêmement judicieux
sur le contrefactuel en particulier
c'est pas dans les missions de du hcfp
de faire des scénarios
je peux quand même vous donner un ordre
de grandeur parce qu'on peut y
travailler
c'est que les modèles
disent en gros que 0,5% de croissance en
moins c'est 0,2 points de déficit
supplémentaire donc dans l'hypothèse par
exemple ou la croissance serait bien à
0,9 est pas un 4 le déficit serait de
0,2 supplémentaire ce qui veut dire que
pour parvenir à 4,4 je reviens dessus il
faudrait à ce moment-là faire soit les
prélèvements supplémentaires soit les
communes supplémentaires et en effet le
rapporteur général j'ai lu comme vous
son très bonne interview dans l'opinion
et j'ai été auditionné déjà par la
commission des finances sur la LPF lundi
il n'est pas estimé que ce que nous
disions était invraisemblable il a pris
très au sérieux comme d'ailleurs
l'ensemble des députés je dois dire et
en effet Monsieur Ferro conçoit une
droite ou de gauche il faut quand même
basé
nos raisonnements c'est donné assez
réaliste et dans ce sens là je pense que
le Conseil joue un rôle très utile nous
sommes plutôt dans la vie qu'aujourd'hui
la prévision centrale est à 09 4,4 ça
veut pas dire que demain la réalisation
s'appelle mais en fonction évidemment on
impact sur le déficit de pré-être devra
être apprécier
sur
la question de savoir si le déficit 2023
est crédible
le hcfp le juge crédible madame
sénatrice parce que le seul budgétaire
c'est pas le déficit c'est pas tout à
fait la même façon de comptabiliser
certaines recettes notamment européennes
et donc nous pensons qu'en effet le
déficit annonça 4,9 est crédible
plausible comme nous le disons mais
c'est aussi sans doute une question à
poser au ministre qui va pouvoir
détailler les choses davantage que
nous le faisons
pour ce qui concerne
les dépenses ou faire des économies
le respect de
est-ce que je dois plus réel présenté
par le gouvernement suppose la
réalisation d'un important montant
d'économie en dépense de nature a
infléchir la progression spontanée de la
dépense publique
c'est pas notre mandat de faire des
conseils de les conseils moi de faire
des recommandations sur des mesures à
prendre je dirais toutefois et je le
redis que le changement de méthode me
paraît crucial essentiel je reviens sur
les rues de dépenses là le rôle du
Parlement pardon tout à fait central
sans aucun doute et je vous redis que
nous sommes disponibles vous savez que
nous pouvons faire des 58 2 à votre
demande
la Cour des comptes pour le coup et là
pour se faire puisque je parle de la
Cour des comptes je rappelle qu'elle a
produit 9 notes thématiques je vais
changer mes sujets parce que je dis
toujours éducation
et hôpital et logement le logement c'est
quand même un vrai sujet la politique
publique très coûteuse dont l'efficacité
à la fois en termes de construction en
terme de présence dans le parc social et
quand même il faut la changer je dis pas
qu'il faut la réduire il faut quand même
qu'elle soit qu'elle produit des
résultats mais je prends deux autres
exemples les dépenses fiscales dépenses
fiscales
leur nombre est considérable
lors durée est infinie ou indéfini en
tout cas leur contrôle est quasi nul
et nous proposons la Cour des comptes à
certaines de règles mesure-t-il de bon
sens comme le fait de les plafonner dans
la durée de les évaluer et donc de leur
mettre en question voilà quand même un
travail qui doit être fait c'est un
montant de 90 milliards d'euros je dis
pas du tout que 90 milliards d'euros à
gagner il y a sûrement quelque chose à
gagner et aussi la question du
verdissement ou du brunissement des
dépenses qui doit être posées il y a les
aides aux entreprises sur lequel ils ont
produit également une autre qui montre
oui il faut des entreprises mais toutes
les aides aux entreprises là aussi
peuvent rencontrer les mêmes
caractéristiques le nombre la durée
indéfinie l'absence de contrôle
et c'est aussi un montant assez
important bref la revue des dépenses
doit permettre de faire tout ça
systématiquement sur la totalité du
périmètre de la dépense publique et oui
j'ai une conviction très profonde c'est
que sans austérité je le redis on peut
faire le quantum d'économie de 12
milliards qui est demandé de manière
intelligente sans recourir au rabot et
sont taper systématiquement sur les
mêmes politiques en ayant des
performances plus grandes éventuellement
une justice plus grande question
d'orientation mais je travaille doit
être fait c'est un changement culturel
et mon pressentiment c'est que si on ne
le fait pas
on se racontera quand même de faire 12
milliards mais dans des conditions les
plus douloureuses et pas avec des choix
optimaux
et ça nous prépare des lendemains qui
sont pas drôles voilà pourquoi
l'intelligence là est vraiment une
nécessité absolue et je le dis devant
vous
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs sur
l'impact la réforme des retraites sur
les croissances potentielles le
gouvernement intègre dans les prisons
macchronomiques une croissance
potentielle une augmentation du pays de
0,7 points la raison 2027 suite à la
forme des retraites ce que le hcfp juge
surestimé la réforme des retraites vise
à maintenir les secteurs les seigneurs
en activité plus longtemps
sont les projections de la CNAV et de
l'Insee ça traduira par une hausse du
taux d'activité de 0,4 et un point de
pourcentage à horizon 2027 compris entre
les deux la prévision de taux d'activité
du gouvernance se situe entre celle de
l'acteur made Insee raisonnable ça veut
pas dire pour autant que le taux
d'emploi augmentera autant de prévu pour
le gouvernement parce qu'il faudrait
pour ça que les entreprises adoptent
leur comportement pour offrir un emploi
à ses actifs supplémentaires et que la
demande qu'il aurait adressée augmente
en même temps et ça n'a rien à qui donc
les hypothèses d'emploi et ça c'est
quelque chose que nous avons constaté à
toutes les auditions que nous avons
faites
sont plus optimistes du point de vue du
gouvernement que la totalité des
instituts de prévision et ça un lien
direct avec ce que je viens de dire sur
les retraites
enfin par rapport à la question c'est
et là aussi c'est sans doute des
questions qu'il faut poser au ministre
la semaine dernière s'est réuni
ce que le ministre rappelle au Conseil
des finances publiques locales
qui est composé des présidents des trois
associations d'élus principales les
régions les départements les communes
plus les ministres concernés
plus le premier président de la Cour des
comptes
je n'ai pas pu y assister les présidents
et rapporteurs
disons que l'objectif de 0,5 est
objectif ambitieux qu'il n'y a pas de
mesure contraignantes existantes et
envisagée et que je suis au conseil donc
j'ai compris qu'il avait surtout un rôle
consultatif deux fois par an était de
nature à chercher un consensus faire des
échanges de bonne pratique d'ailleurs
c'est pas tout à fait au conseil quand
même si on est logique le Conseil des
finances publiques a une existence de
pas avoir organique définit une
trajectoire il auditionne des gens y
réunit des personnalités indépendantes
et extrêmement diverses je le signal au
passage pour ceux qui s'interrogent sur
le Conseil ça va
les gens sont très très divers et pas
bien toujours un consensus d'ailleurs
certains sont très à gauche donc ne sont
beaucoup moins
mais néanmoins
la ville au Conseil est partagée partout
sans le moindre réserve
bon disons que ce n'est pas simple
monsieur le sénateur et que ça mérite
sans doute oui des questions parce que
je reviens du point de conseil pas du
tout d'un point de vue politique ou
d'appréciation de politique publique ou
de processus publics
pour ce qui nous concerne nous voyons
que c'est un élément de l'équilibrage
peut-être qu'il est présenté
et que l'hypothèse là encore paraît
favorable en l'absence de consensus en
l'absence de mesures contraignantes
compte tenu des besoins investissements
et certains facteurs politiques que vous
connaissez mieux que moi
donc comment il parvenir bonne question
pas inatteignable
mais gros effort
j'ai l'impression monsieur Feraud que la
question vous revient en boomerang
je pense que c'est cette partie des
sujets qui proposer aux questions qu'il
faut poser au gouvernement parce que la
question du module supérieur pour le
coup c'est pas notre travail
constatons nous que l'hypothèse telle
qu'elle est favorable et qu'elle pèse
merci monsieur le Président d'une part
d'être venu ce matin nous présenter ces
deux ces deux documents importants pour
nos travaux
et d'autre part nous aurons plaisir
évidemment à vous retrouver dans le
cadre de la réflexion alors vous vous
collègues dans le cadre de la réflexion
évidemment sur sur le PLF et comme vous
le savez nous sommes nous sommes
toujours très attentifs aux travaux qui
sont réalisés tout au long de l'année
par la Cour
pour le coup
pour alimenter nos propres réflexions
sur
le projet de loi de finances merci
encore merci à ceux qui vous
accompagnent et bonne journée
je rappelle à nos collègues que nous
nous retrouvons à 16 heures